[Music]
thank you so much Pete it's a real
pleasure to be back at data engine off
for the second year in a row and I'm
joined by some really illustrious
panelists and I'm going to begin the
panel by asking each of you to introduce
yourselves and talk a little bit about
what you do emoji or do you want to
start us off you guys all right so my
name is Ahmad you I do did a science
I get hub before before I went to get
hub I was finishing my PhD at Berkeley
welcome currently working at Google
Google Docs specifically collating
nonprofit investment in computer science
education
I'm extremely nosy as a human being so
data science it's perfect for me I just
like to know stuff so I can't believe
that we actually get paid to do this
general high so I hope you guys can hear
me too huh so I'm Jennifer I'm the head
of data science at Atlassian in case you
don't know what a lation is I'm pretty
sure you use at least one of our
products so we're the company that makes
a confluence JIRA HipChat
Trello and a ton of other things that
pretty much everybody is using for some
reason people know the products not
necessarily the company so that's why
I'm mentioning that so I joined a little
bit less than a year ago to start a
brand new data science team over there
because Atlassian was a server company
for a long time so there was a ton of
data being generated but unfortunately
we didn't get to look at it and so
eventually the company started migrating
to the cloud lots of opportunities and
like many other companies they started
realizing that there is a huge
opportunity so prior to last year and I
was working I mean I was managing the
science in the search team at Walmart
labs and I'm originally a particle
physicist and Shuba so I'm Java and I
read some of the design set for it set
Salesforce Einstein
we're building a platform to enable all
the hundreds of thousands of businesses
that use Salesforce to much more easily
use machine learning in their day to day
businesses and so prior to Salesforce I
worked at LinkedIn I used to work on
search and before that I worked at
Microsoft Bing on making incorporating
social signals into search results
alright so we're the were the past
present and future panel so I guess
we'll go in a chronological order and
start with the past I'm curious what I'm
curious for each of you to tell us about
what is a hard problem that you are
proud to have solved in the past but now
it's you know now it's done now it's now
it's sorted how about how about all
right go emoji than a few hundred and
Jennifer I'll keep it okay so the
machine learning team at github is
fairly new we started in January 2017
and because of that that meant that that
means that we're building the team as
well as building the infrastructure to
support machine learning at the same
time and we built a recommendation
engine I don't know a lot of people if
you log into github I mean look at how
maybe I think everybody pretty much uses
github but it's your [ __ ] joke ants
get up users everybody yeah so if you
log in and you go to the dashboard the
second tab is actually a recommendation
engine I know most of us just go
straight to the URL of our repos that
recommendation engine is something that
were very very proud of that we built
because we're able to build it at the
same time as we're building our team as
well as building infrastructure so it
makes us not have to leave outside of
machine learning and going to data
engineering as well so working together
going all the way from ETL to production
in a very short amount of time it's
something that we extremely proud of and
I want you guys to actually use that
product and also leverage the social
graph on github follow people like stuff
say your recommendations can be better
and we're very very proud of the quality
of recommendations because sometimes we
actually use the recommended repos to
build a product to recommend even more
to hunt
okay so briar does sales for us I used
to work in the consumer space so as to
work on at LinkedIn and Bing and the
problems that we worked on were work
that I worked on we're pretty
constrained in a sense so I had to solve
for one very well understood problem
with a very well understood objective
using data that I understood really well
and that I had good intuition for it
because I used these products myself and
I found that transitioning to the
enterprise space was just a completely
different beast we had written your
thing we had you know we were trying to
make machine learning accessible to the
hundreds of thousands of businesses that
use Salesforce applications and they've
all customized these applications for
their own needs and they use it for all
kinds of things so the diversity of data
and the diversity of use cases and the
diversity of business processes is just
mind-boggling and so my team from like
the very first product we started
working on we've had to build a lot of
automation so how do you automatically
do the things that a data scientist
would do when every single data said
that they work on because we just don't
have an update assigned us to do you
know to solve all these problems for all
these businesses and so that has been
extremely technically challenging you
know especially like when you don't when
you when you're working with unknown
business processes things like even just
separating out calls from effect can be
very difficult to do and so so it's been
technically very challenging but at the
same time really rewarding because
ultimately we're we're making machine
learning accessible to people who don't
necessarily have a PhD in machine
but they have a lot of domain expertise
that they can bring to the table so
that's something that I'm pretty proud
of working on Jennifer yeah so like I
mentioned before I come from a
unconventional background so I'm
originally a particle physicist so
basically my story is that the first
time I actually took a data science job
I actually become a manager by accident
because by the time I joined the company
after signing my manager eventually left
and the entire the entire venture was
essentially starting a brand new data
science function so I ended up like by
accident having to build a data science
team from scratch and so I I don't know
how I pulled this off but like somehow I
was able to hire like seven people
really quickly and I actually realize
like this is something that I'm actually
pretty good at and it's actually very
challenging it so I'm just like a
actually like over and over like I
actually really enjoy building teams
from scratch because there is the
technical aspect of the challenge but
there is also like a cultural aspect to
the challenge and so if I have to think
about like you know Lika bringing data
to achieve and like making companies the
inter century been making teams
data-driven I think you know like there
is one thing I'm really really proud of
and it's actually what happened in my
previous job at Walmart labs so
basically I actually joined the search
team and so the reason why I joined the
search team compared to like an Amazon
or something else actually wanted to be
in e-commerce was one what is a very
different challenge to actually like a
when you work there Walmart is a company
that's mostly brick-and-mortar right and
so one of the problems that the search
team for e-commerce has there is that
people would actually new search to try
and check the inventory in their nearby
stores right so when you think of using
machine learning for search it's
actually a huge problem because you
don't have a clean feedback loop right
and so people would actually search for
band-aids and they would actually have
absolutely zero intent to order online
they actually just want to see if this
is available in the university because
they don't want to drive there to find
out that I
that is not available right and so I
actually realized it's a huge problem
it's why I actually set up my mind to go
and try and fix this problem and I
realized that the data scientist on my
team actually didn't have access to
stores data because you know like the
data scientist on the e-commerce site
had access to ecommerce data and the
data scientist on the store side had
access to source data and I really
pushed really hard on my manager my
managers manager went all the way up to
the CEO and the CEO that we actually
need to leverage our data better because
we are not going to be able to solve
this type of problems right and so
eventually they gave me the budget to
build a team that was just focused on
leveraging data across the board and we
were able to like accomplished really
amazing things that Nautica nobody was
able to tackle before right
and so it makes you realize that even a
company like Walmart and Walmart was one
of the first company to actually like
leverage the italic they were already
gathering they tied in the 90s when
nobody else was actually realizing what
the eita could bring to a company still
they were missing out on something
really really important that even in the
case of like their e-commerce business
they could leverage stores data because
there there was so much more than that
look at and yeah that's what I think and
this is something that I'm really really
proud of I mean you said something
interesting there which is you talked
about creating a data culture what does
that mean to you how do you create a
data culture especially if you're you
know as many of you have done if you're
coming into a company that was not
previously a data company and is kind of
trying to acquire a data culture what
does that mean I mean so I mean formula
it's a it's mostly a cultural change
right I mean so basically like something
that I see in my current job is like a
so when I came into Atlassian I mean
that you have to pull the parking on the
ETF for like understanding customer
churn or whatever but nobody was
leveraging the atashi build the data
product right and so I came into this
environment where people are very
engineering oriented like think about it
right I mean Atlassian is the the
company that makes software for software
engineers to perform their jobs better
right and
you actually start realizing that oh you
know like they we should be using a
child because that lesson is all about
agile but agile for the science what
does it mean right I mean how can we
leverage agile
return on investment on a data science
team is completely different than return
and investment that you would see for
engineering right and so how do I
communicate that to the stakeholders how
do I communicate with my product manager
how do I communicate with my engineering
team so it's a lot of patience a lot of
teaching a lot of educational you know
like talking or whatever you have to
address different audiences differently
because they see the problem for a
different angle and for me like it's
mostly about like educating people Roger
you were a founding member of the data
team at getting up over where we were
experiences they're like what what had
to change about the culture so found a
member of the machine learning team they
already had analytics mm-hmm the
interesting thing about github is a few
years back it was an organization with
no management so it was all completely
flat and a lot of products were driven
by engineers because they're building
products for themselves and the biggest
challenge that I have seen and though
we're actually going through is to
empower the engineers to actually
understand they don't know they don't
need to understand high dimensional
spaces and vector representations they
don't need to know any of that stuff but
they just need to know a few primitives
so as you're designing products and id8
and around product I want you to be able
to think about could prediction help me
here could relevance help me here could
ranking help me here so given them like
those few primitives like predict rank
recommend just things that you can
easily think about and see if I could
recommend something in this workflow
will this help this product become
better so they then see ah this is where
machine learning and a data product can
actually come through so it's been about
education but an education that they
don't need to go deep into but just
something they can count off in their
hand wrap their brains around and
actually reason about it so the biggest
challenge for us is helping people
supporting people in reasoning about
product from the data product
perspective so it's all about education
it's a similar thing here so there's
been a lot of education especially with
product managers around well why is why
do you think that this is something that
would be good to build like what data do
you have to back it up
have you instrumented your product
correctly so that you can actually
measure the impact of what you're
building and how can you quickly get out
something without boiling the ocean and
iteratively it really iteratively
release stuff and get signal and improve
and I think just getting getting product
on the same page has been a big piece of
improving the culture around data moving
on to the present day you know if I
think about data science and machine
learning you know in the news in the
sort of national consciousness I feel
like what's actually sort of top of the
headlines right now is you know Mark
Zuckerberg getting grilled and by
Congress and and just kind of all these
looming concerns about data privacy
about the potential for automation and
job loss about the you know the
possibilities that that a eyes can
encode bias and discrimination and and
you know I maybe people have always had
fears about new technologies this this
feels like much more significant to me
than fears people had about the cloud or
mobile what are what are our
responsibilities as do you take these
concerns seriously what are our
responsibilities as as practitioners
either to to sort of explode the the
myths or or to take substantive problems
you know and and solve them maybe we'll
start with Shiva then come this way one
of the areas I think a lot about is bias
and I think it stems from so the thing
is that
Misch I guess machine learning machine
learned models are only as good as the
data that you feed them right and a lot
of this data comes with deeply ingrained
human biases and human prejudices and so
as we're automating more and more things
through machine learning more and more
decisions there's this danger that we're
taking these biases from data to
decisions and so we have a really big
responsibility here to to be able to
measure and to be able to fix for these
things because we want to ultimately
design for the society that we want to
live in and so I think this we need to
tackle this at many levels first of all
the the the teams that build these AI
applications need to be need to reflect
the diversity of the populations that
they're building these applications for
so a classic example I think was you
know there was this time when seatbelt
car manufacturers were making seatbelts
and they were only training on male
models and so the result was that women
and children were still dying and so I
think having a lack of diversity in your
design team and your in your teams in
general results in poor design choices
so I think we have to start with the
teams that are building these products
we also need to bring much more
transparency and and insights into the
models themselves and why they're you
know provide insights into the factors
that are in that are influencing the
predictions or the explained ability
explainable and even even at the level
it's like a particular decision that was
made why was this decision made what was
the main influencing factor being able
to provide those kind that kind of
transparency is it's an important area
of research and it's and it's important
that we put more and more effort into
this and then I also think that just
generally having metrics around
everything like you if there are certain
things that you care about like race or
gender than having metrics and knowing
how you're doing against those
particular
those particular categories is important
because you can't start to you can't
start to fix what you can't measure and
so I think there's a number of there's a
number of levels at which we need to
think about this and ultimately though
I'm kind of hopeful because I think you
know you could train a machine to
overcome its biases by giving it better
data but how do you train a human to to
overcome his prejudices right so I think
how are you Jennifer so I think my you
know like a specific queries and the
context of my job might be slightly
different but it's probably a problem
you have yourselves at at st. marks
right I mean so on think of the data
that Atlassian has written so basically
like a little bit over like a hundred
thousand different customers customers
many companies using our services right
I mean so basically you know like
user-generated content for at lesson is
like pretty much everything that you
cannot find on Google right I mean so
basically what Tesla is working on
basically like all the secrets of what
happens at an enterprise level are stuck
somewhere in our data right I mean so
obviously like we're being very careful
with this data and we want to make sure
that we're not leaking like very
critical information from one company to
another right I mean so typically like
the type of you like products who are
trying to be a lot like recommendation
systems and these type of things right I
mean so when you're building like a
collaborative filtering model for
recommendations obviously you're just
gonna use the data of each one of these
companies separately right and so you
need to deplete duplicate the same model
over and over again because I'm not
gonna recommend something from a content
from Tesla to someone from Netflix right
obviously but then you have like more
advanced kind of things like trying to
profile a specific user right because
for example if I can say that a specific
user is a product manager maybe I can
start ranking things differently in
search so that they can find a content
that's more appropriate right so we're
thinking about building these models
that help us profile users and question
is do you want to do that on a customer
by customer basis obviously you would
have enough data to do that properly and
you're trying to do that more at
industry level or even across all of our
customers question then right I mean so
what does it mean to leak information
across different companies right and so
knowing when you are going to leak
actual content is very easy right but
when you are going to leak like patterns
hidden information right I mean coded
information from one company to another
is it ok is it something that's gonna be
you know like possible to reverse
engineer for someone else right I mean
there is a very common problem for
search specifically like all the
basically you can backtrack and try to
figure out what exists in other
instances by just looking at the ranking
scores from another company right and
the question is like there are new
regulations like GDP are right I mean
GDP are is coming soon but even for me
like III know how to how many of you are
familiar with GDP are how many of you
are like Judea GDP are is not a concern
it's no sweat
okay next question
so I actually expend a lot of time
saying like I get it what it means to be
forgotten right I mean interest erase
the specific users data from the system
but what I've learned about this user
what do I need to do with that and I
spent so much time like talking to the
lawyers like is it okay to keep that if
you can you know like if you cannot like
directly identify this person it's okay
you can keep it what does it mean like
if you have a reasonable doubt about who
this person is right I mean in your data
I'm just like what is reasonable right I
don't know you figure it out right I
mean so it really makes you realize that
something so critical so crucial or
whatever and you think how important
that is with like the zuker we're
hearing right I mean basically like ah
we still have a lot of work to get done
in terms of like identifying what is
okay and what is not okay and for me as
a data science manager it's really
worrisome that I have to make some of
these decisions myself so sometimes we
just pose and you just decide not to do
things because we're scared of what the
implications might be those hearings are
definitely not not reassuring that the
lawmakers are in a position to make
these
how about you emoji when I think about
some of the things that keep me up at
night is the idea of the impending maybe
it's my impending maybe already here
the fourth Industrial Revolution mmm so
moving towards automation and what does
that do to society you know does that
disrupt society in a positive way does
that disrupt society in a negative way
and whatever it is what's the outcome
and what can we do if we feel like
there's gonna be a negative effect on
society at large what can we do to
mitigate that effect which is one of the
major reasons that led me to a place
like github because github has all this
massive amount of computational data so
we have a role to play in how we are
going to fix some of these challenges
and if we're moving towards knowledge
work that means that we might be able to
create something in the time to create
the future of augmented knowledge
workers and with all our data we can
then use our data to help kind of lower
the barrier to entry by building
artificial intelligence that support
people and how they learn very
futuristic very interesting however if I
have to support you and how you're going
to learn and these are the kind of
things I want to do that means that I
need to know a little bit about you
which gets to information that is
literally about you so I can really help
you get things done for yourself and we
don't have that kind of information it's
not the kind of information that we keep
on any of our users because we that's
not been something we've been interested
in and we just want to support people so
it opens this whole new Pandora's box
around this time everybody is watching
everybody is already freaking out about
data and data privacy so building
certain kind of products requires you to
have a certain kind of information about
a user and so it comes back again to the
idea of Education what how do we help
the public understand what happens in
data companies and the kinds of
information that data companies collect
about them our users gonna be okay with
us collecting data about you if that
data is used to serve you better
what like where does that line drawn and
so it's also conversations with legal
what can we do what can we not do so
that's one part another part is making
sure that your building data products
that are free and fair of bias against
humans things that are not going to hurt
the humans negatively and in a global
company it's that's a very interesting
problem you want to make sure that the
data products you build do not affect
people who are marginalized in their
society marginalized in their society so
in the American context we have
protected persons does that hold for
Australia does that hold for China does
that hold for Nigeria if the African
American black people are protected
persons in the United States and I have
something that is gonna deal with that
that model is not gonna work in Nigeria
because everybody is African and
everybody's black so these are now
questions of these are the things
they're just like oh my god it's not
trivial it's not trivial at all and I go
back to building interdisciplinary
expertise we are at the point now that
applied mathematics is not enough these
are not just pure math problems anymore
these are problems that require you to
meet with a lawyer maybe meet with their
social psychologist maybe meet with this
so we actually need to start looking to
hire people with interdisciplinary
expertise if we cannot do that if those
people don't exist we need to partner
with people in other social sciences to
actually help us in answering these
kinds of questions better so we can
build that knowledge into our products I
think that's where we are and that's
kind of approach we should actually take
I've often it's interesting to me is I
think we've actually never been at a
better moment for collaboration with
social science I mean I think arguably
technology I love what you just said I
think arguably technology always needed
to be deeply concerned with social
science but but in some ways because of
the emphasis on stats like I think it
you know these days a sociology
sociology major graduates with more
statistics than many CS majors do and
and so data may finally give us the
bridge that you know the common ground
between the the social and the computer
sciences or that'll be my glass
half-full take
I'm curious in this audience how many of
you are concerned that AI is going to
replace jobs that it's going to destroy
jobs currently occupied by human beings
how many of you are worried that AI is
going to replace your job all right I
don't know if I have the answer but I
think that gives us a responsibility
right everybody in this room and
hopefully it gives us some empathy too
let's talk about the future then this is
probably a good segue from the from the
present to the future voice of God there
so when you think about I'm gonna I'm
gonna stick I'm I'm just an optimist I'm
a believer actually I mean I think we
need to be aware of potential problems
so that we have so that we are empowered
to solve those problems I believe we
will find solutions to problems that we
know about and care about but but I'm
gonna when I think about the future I'm
we've already talked about the scary
things but let's let's talk about the
great things what's coming that you're
excited for like what's just what's just
or one on the corner and we can't wait
not like the far future like Oh some day
you know rocket ships I don't know
I can now rocket ships tomorrow so
that's not the far future anymore but
you know what's what's what's just was
just coming what's what since what's in
line of sight but we just aren't there
yet okay so I can I sit next to a team
that first of all how many of you are
computer science undergraduates how many
of you actually did computer science at
your job I think that's not the case I
think most of us are doing software
engineering you're not at your work
doing big o-notation and and things like
that and figuring out NP you know you're
not doing any of this kind of stuff
because who does that however people
don't really do that turns out software
engineers doing anyway computer
scientists still do however in a place
like github where we have this giant
troop of code we're finally at a place
where it's just like yes yes I can
finally do computer science because the
thing that is around the corner
hopefully within two to five years is
moving towards a system that has a
version of automated coding so not
automating the machine learning pipeline
but literally automating things
these are we have some design patterns
that are so so obvious that we keep
writing over and over and over again
things like a for loop if you've written
one for loop once you write it again
like it's just the same exact primitive
the for loop what if we could actually
just do that for you so around the
corner we're gonna get to a future where
you as a software engineer somebody
who's writing code spends most of your
time on the creative aspects of code
you're not they're trying to build some
development environment you're on earth
they're writing things that don't really
help you get far so the human does what
the human can do very very well which is
rock creativity the Machine does all the
boring stuff that the machine can do
very very well so that is something that
is very exciting for me I'm trying to
build a product for somebody that has a
great idea and feels like oh I can't get
this idea to market because I don't know
how to code it I don't know how to do
this I don't have to do that I want that
person to come on the github platform
and maybe they put three months of
effort they can build a prototype of
something and deploy it without having
to fight through everything that we're
gonna get to in the next five years I'm
I'm excited about AI augmented
intelligence okay so basically like a I
know everyone in this room is excited
about like the prospect of everything
being automated and like I see like
fancy AI applications but I think we
kind of missed a step right I mean so
for example I worked on search right I
mean try to evaluate search relevance
without using human input right I mean
this is something that it's just mind
bubbling about boggling that just like
even Google is still using like a ton of
like a crowdsourcing to identify like a
you know like a what is relevance right
and so I think there is a huge pool of
like new applications we are not even
foreseen yet that's not like
human-in-the-loop right I mean what
happens when you are actually in putting
humans together with machines rather
than just jumping to the machine doing
everything on its own right so you know
like think about chess right I mean so
who is able like to win
chess competitions today right i mean so
obviously we know that the human has
been bit by the machine but like now the
best teams in the world are like
combinations of computers with humans
right because we humans are really good
at strategizing thinking about the
future right where we really suck at is
like we're you know like we're human so
we make silly little mistakes right I
mean so basically like a this is where
the machine can help us like a
automating making sure that we are not
like making a like a coding mistake
somewhere right I mean are really making
sure that we can see your like the high
dimensionality cases and be able to
evaluate all the different possibilities
and when you bring these two together I
think there's gonna be a huge potential
of new applications we're not even
thinking about today and that may be
completely fruitful fully-fledged like a
5-10 years from now chupa bring us home
I think so what excites me most is I
think that there's some there I think
there are some industries that stand to
be completely disrupted by AI by data
science and a big example of that is
healthcare I think so the fact that you
know you can now have image recognition
capabilities on a mobile phone just
imagine the possibilities for medical
diagnostics in rural areas in developing
countries that don't have access to
proper medical facilities right so I
think there are those kinds of there are
those kinds of things in healthcare and
customer service and other such areas
that are going to be completely
disrupted I also think that AI will
fundamentally change the way we connect
with each other and with the world and a
great example of this as I was reading
recently about Google pixel buds you
know the fact that you have real-time
translation it's like the Babel Fish is
here right so that to me is that's
amazing I was also reading about this a
Stanford experiment where they were able
to use Google glasses to help autistic
children infer you know certain cues
social cues from facial expressions so
so I really think that AI is going to
change how we interact with
each other how we interact with the
world and then I'm also excited that
it's going to as both of you mentioned
it's going to take care of the mundane
the repetitive the dangerous and it's
really going to free up humans to do
what humans do best fantastic all right
I think we've got time for a couple of
audience questions the audience is still
asleep
I think somebody's running a mic is that
one right there
right here labeled a - like a boss
thank you for the panel and starting off
the conference I liked Geneva what you
said that you believe in a hybrid future
of human and machine and I think you
were also referring to Gary Kasparov who
said that machines will beat the best
human that human plus machine will beat
the best machine how do you think that
we can bring these both worlds together
in a like very efficient and effective
way so how would you think that it ten
years from now humans and machines
collaborate right now most of like you
know like you we use like crowdsourcing
and many different industries to
actually you know like focus on I mean
you you label data and this is where the
human plays a role right I mean so you
label like a relevant scores for like a
specific queries etc I think that
somehow active learning so the ability
of continuously like ping I don't know I
feel like I do you know the details of
active learning but active learning is
basically like a-- okay one of the
biggest problem we have now is like deep
learning is data greedy so you have to
tag a ton of data and it's really
expensive and it's not really efficient
right I mean so active learning is
really about you just ask what you call
an Oracle so it can be a human or
another system so to basically like give
you you know like a label when you need
to write them so basically you would
build a system you would predict
something you would get some data out of
this and you would tell you like a level
of confidence on your answer and if your
level of confidence sucks you're just
gonna ask a human please tell me this is
actually true orally please like provide
more and more data and so I think it's
really a smart way to incorporate a
continuous feedback from the human in
the loop that's actually going to help
us like do much more because right now
we're really stuck by this problem that
we cannot label every single data point
because we're in an era of the data and
we cannot label everything manually
hi thank you all for your participation
on this panel everything has been great
I especially loved what you had to say
about for me the first time I heard this
particular twist on like data-driven
because like whenever management would
come to me and say we have to be
data-driven it's like how do we make
better decisions but this whole question
of in product design how do we embed
data science to empower users to make
better decisions which I think it's
awesome the question I wanted to ask was
kind of a flip extension of that we've
been talking about data science the
other half of this conference is data
engineering what do you need from us to
enable you to do these things and I
don't have to like tie this tie that
tight
ETL should not be a nightmare I should
not have to like cook all these things
together so I need infrastructure that
is extremely robust at scale and ways of
detecting errors in the infrastructure
very very fast so that I'm not doing
like whack-a-mole
like okay let me go to the server looks
what did this no it wasn't that was it
that no so just better diagnostics under
overlooked and just having robust
metrics so that you can do this kind of
really quick diagnosis it's very useful
one of the things that I see so when I
join Atlassian which is like a a
question is this amazing culture of like
a hackathons and you know like
innovation and so I actually found out
that there were more than 60% of all a
Katherine's ever that were machine
learning oriented and there was no
machine learning engineering team before
I joined right I mean so really tells
you that people there are a lot of
people who know how to build a model
there are very few people who know how
to operationalize a model how to deploy
a model right I mean so basically like a
for me like I made it my mission when
internet lesson to actually be able to
provide solutions to deploy models at
scale for even people who don't
necessarily have the background to do
that
and so it's a really a task where you
need some data science to actually like
leverage the knowledge or the the model
that is being built but you also need to
build a pipeline or system that is easy
to use for someone who's not a
specialist right and so I think by doing
that we're really going to explode like
the ability because like within that
lesson it's a huge problem like if I had
this available today we would have
smarts in all the products like tomorrow
because they're they're such a huge pool
of talented people and models are just
sitting there that cannot be deployed
because we don't have the right
infrastructure be great had something
for model management
[Laughter]
you